-Hey, welcome back.
We're here with Andy Samberg
and the cast,
Kenan Thompson, John Mulaney
and writers Colin Jost
and Rob Klein of tonight's
"Second Chance Theater."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, Andy,
we'll start with you.
How do you feel it played?
-I'm feeling like I wish I had
changed before this part.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Right, that you're still
in full Griff Banks,
you're still wearing the wig
-Yeah.
Starting to regret that
a little bit.
-You mean it's hard
to get out of character.
-Yeah.
-You're so method about it
-What did you just say to me
[ Laughter ]
-Do you, Rob and Colin, do you
remember writing this sketch
-Very well.
[ Laughter ]
-And did it sort of fly off --
fly onto the page, I should say?
Did the inspiration
just come fast and furious
-Yeah, I think
Griff kind of wrote it.
-Yeah, yeah,
Griff kind of wrote himself.
-Griff wrote it for us.
[ Laughter ]
-To dress twice.
Do you remember the two hosts?
-Emma Stone and Gabourey Sidibe.
-Yeah, there you go.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-Classic find-and-replace, yeah.
Did you -- Do you remember -
Well, you were in it both times.
Do you feel like it
played well enough to go to --
-I was in it both times?
-Yeah.
-Nice.
[ Laughter ]
-Sure.
Um, yeah, I loved it.
[ Laughter ]
Each and every time.
-John, you have some
other favorites of Andy's that
did not find their way to air.
Do you want to share
some of those with us?
-This wasn't on air?
Griff Banks?
-This was never aired.
-Oh, it went to dress.
-Yeah, it went to dress.
-Which is right before air
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Then they cut it.
[ Laughter ]
-We worked on a piece,
I think it was Friday nigh
till about 4:00 a.m.,
called --
It was an "Update" feature
You did "Update."
-Yeah, I did, yeah, yeah.
-It was called
"The Guy Who Just Woke Up.
So Andy would come out,
and he'd be like, "Ahh."
He'd be tired, you know?
He just woke up.
And I remember we got off
the elevator at 4:00 a.m.,
and we had turned it in,
and we were in the lobby.
And we all wanted to go home
and Andy said, "Oh, wait.
Maybe we should call him
Bedhead Jones."
[ Laughter ]
And...
you know, we were like --
we were like, "I don't know.
Bedhead Jones.
We kind of want to go home,"
but looking back, I think that
you know,
that would've saved it."
-Yeah, I think it would've
Would've put it over the top
-I realize today
how many of your character
that we worked on had the entire
premise of the sketch
in the name of the character
-Right.
Well, you got to let them know
up front.
-All the jokes.
[ Laughter ]
-There was Gerald.
-Gerald who's always sick.
Also cut.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, never aired.
-Gerard, the worse dude ever
also cut.
-Gerard, the worst dude ever
[ Laughter ]
Do you remember a couple thing
about Gerard?
Couple of details I remember
of Gerard, he rode in on a -
What do they call it?
Recumbent bike?
-Recumbent bike.
-Teva sandals.
-Tevas and socks.
-He followed -- He was lik
a Deadhead but for Jamiroquai.
-Yeah, the Quai.
[ Laughter ]
He followed the Quai.
-We referred to them as the --
-He's on tour with the Quai.
[ Laughter ]
-He had an iguana
named Gary Larson.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep, creator of "The Far Side."
-Who was it that liked
Martinelli's
sparkling apple cider?
-That was --
-I texted you on Thanksgiving.
-We just
were talking about this.
-Lomax.
-Lomax!
-Yeah, Lomax.
-None of these aired.
[ Laughter ]
-Can you do Lomax's voice for us
for a second?
-Oh, and truly.
Such a pleasure to see you
[ Laughter ]
Would you like another glass o
Martinelli's sparkling cider
the world's most perfect
beverage?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like I'm in the roo
with Lomax.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Colin, you -- we were --
You know, we e-mailed
this script around
because we were talking abou
doing this,
and you made an observatio
about Griff Banks,
that it was sort of --
it was foreshadowing
the future of American politics.
-That's right.
I didn't realize
that Griff Banks
would essentially become
President of the United States
[ Laughter ]
-But basically,
a sensitive bully...
-Sensitive bully.
-...would be exactly
who would hold
the highest office.
-Andy, good job.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Finger on the future pulse
-Do you think he would own u
to being a gaping snorf?
[ Laughter ]
-So gaping snorf --
looking back, do you feel like
"gaping snorf" played as wel
as you had hoped it would play
-Truthfully, better.
[ Laughter ]
-What about the second time?
-Second time.
When amber said it?
-Yeah, because you say it,
and then,
another character says it.
-Well, what was nice is,
we cut to Seth in the middle
[ Laughter ]
And Klein and I were talking
we were like,
"That was our mistake at 'SNL.
We should've cut to Lorne.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
It would've been fun.
Just in general,
there should be a Lorne-ca
that people can watch.
-Oh, my God.
-Right.
-Like, you know, there's
certain, like, football game
where you can just watch
the feed from, like,
a different camera.
-Yeah.
-If there was a Lorne-cam,
that would be amazing.
-Like, mic'd up?
-Yeah.
-Throws his wine glass
against the wall --
"Mother [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
-And he's throwing
the headphones.
[ Laughter ]
-Klein, do you remember
being under the bleachers
for Griff Banks,
thinking this is gonna air
-I remember the first part
of that,
of being under the bleachers
for sure.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I think we thought
it probably would air.
And I think it was maybe
a little controversial
that it didn't air.
-Yeah.
Like, controversial in tha
people cared?
-Like, we were mad about it.
-Yeah.
-Among us three.
[ Laughter ]
-It was a controversy
that still burns today.
-The Gabourey Sidibe one,
it was picked for air.
-Yeah.
-And got cut on air,
and the sketch that played
instead was a Will Forte sketch,
a character he did called
"Hamilton."
-Hamilton Whiteman.
-Yeah.
-And I think
we should've done Griff.
[ Laughter ]
-You're gonna throw your boy
Forte under the bus right now.
-Yeah, yeah!
[ Laughter ]
I mean, everyone thinks
Forte's so nice.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, boy.
That's a --
-I should've took off the wig,
for sure.
[ Laughter ]
-In fairness to Hamilton,
he was, I believe,
an Aryan Nationalist
with a bob haircut.
-Yeah.
-In fairness, yeah.
-They were really --
they were really kind of bot
foreshadowing America.
-Truth.
-Yeah.
-What's the worst --
Do you have a worst moment
under the bleachers with Lorne
as far as --
-Uh...
A worst moment.
-Or, like --
-Oh, my favorite moment
was his son Eddie...
-Yeah.
-Maybe he was 11 at this time.
Lorne was watching a sketc
of ours on the monitor,
and he kept going...
[ Scoffs ]
...like that, you know,
because it wasn't doing well
So, eventually, Eddie just
was staring at him,
and then, Eddie went...
[ Scoffs ]
[ Laughter ]
...mimicking him.
I thought that was cute.
And then, a lot of other times
that were very hurtful, yeah
[ Laughter ]
-At some point like last year,
I was watching a sketch
that they had written,
and it was not going great
and he turned to me
under the bleachers, Lorne
and he said, "Do you think
they can take Emmys away?"
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good one.
-Alex Baze, who ran "Update"
when I was there and is no
the head writer of this show
I did something on "Update."
I tried a new thing where...
I basically looked through
a magnifying glass at some point
and was doing a bit
with a British accent.
And Lorne told Baze,
when it was over, he just said
"Burn the tapes."
[ Laughter ]
Which I don't --
Looking back, I don't thin
Baze should've told me.
[ Laughter ]
-We had a game-show host onc
named Robert Blaze, I think.
And Lorne went,
"Everyone's confused
'cause they think
it's Rubén Blades."
And we were like,
"Oh, no, they're not."
You know?
[ Laughter ]
You know, 47 years?
He knows what he's doing.
-He knows what he's doing.
You guys, congratulations
on it finally finding air.
I'm sorry, you know,
it's on a weeknight,
like, after 1:00 a.m.
-This is better, truthfully.
-Yeah.
-And thank you for giving it
this chance to shine.
[ Laughter ]
-And shine it did.
-Yeah.